monsur
prê toujours à épingles le sourire dans
la VO mich illumine le téléviseur de
millions de Canadiens pendant près de 15
ansdition mercred
novembre mais l'aventure de la grande
dame du petit écran déb une décen plusôt
alors qu'elle devient la première femme
à présent le radio journal des services
français la seuem dansaine des Nell en
français et en anglais les deux réseaux
pendant la guerre curieuse empathique
ses patrons reconnaissent rapidement son
talent ses racines irl-canadiennes lui
permettent de travailler en anglais
comme en
français Montréal lorsque la télévision
fait son apparition en 1952 Michel
tisser fait le saut devant les caméras
télé monéal ouvre le bal puis une fois
de plus Michel tiser innove en devenant
la première femme à animer sa propre
émission rendez-vous avec
les comédiens é interviewé en anglais et
je traduisais rapidement quelques mots
ensuite on passait un truc français puis
d'anglais c'est comme ça que ça se
passait ça se passait très bien personne
ne vous et voici votre Hesse
Michel mais l'émission qui marque sa
carrière est music h pendant 5 ans tous
les dimanches soirs elle fait ombrage
aued suivan show en boutade l'animateur
américain lui demandera de changer de
plage horaire
dans les années 60 Michel ti coanime
avec wifried le moine aujourd'hui la
première grande émission quotidienne
d'affaires publi qui traite de sujets
Chud moi je pense que la télévision a
beaucoup à voir avec la Révolution
tranquille l'ouverture d'esprit des
Québécois puis au début des années 70
michelsorce une nouvelle carrière en
traduction et travaille avec son mari
l'éditeur pierre
reste femme active et retourne même à
l'université à plus de 80 ans pour
compléter son baccalauréat je ne me bat
pas pour obtenir quelque chose je me bat
parce que je trouve qu'en tant qu'être
humain le peu de temps qu'on est là il
faut essayer de faire de son mieux la
grande dame de Radio Canada aura passé
25 ans dans les médias mais toute sa vie
à s'intéresser à ce qu'il
[Musique]
l'entouraitich Ivan côé Radio Canada
Montréal
[Applaudissements]